[Music]
no show on television I think it's fair
to say has moxie in an anchor Chris
Cuomo more often or more gleefully than
this one has but tonight we're gonna
take a break from that this morning
Cuomo announced that like so many
thousands of other people in New York
he's been infected with the krona virus
Cuomo said he's had a fever and
shortness of breath but his main worry
was infecting his wife and children
those are the right priorities Cuomo
said he'll continue to do his show for
as long as he can in isolation from his
basement and we respect that too so
Godspeed to the Cuomo family we are
rooting for you
corta virus is hitting America's economy
in a bad way but it's crushing our once
thriving energy sector which is in a lot
of ways the core of our economy no
matter what they tell you
earlier this month Saudi Arabia began an
oil price war with Russia and that sent
the price of oil crashing now widespread
shutdowns mean fewer cars on the road
fewer flights less industrial activity
all of that means less demand for oil
lower prices and bad news for America's
energy producers it means good news for
you if you use gasoline and were for
that completely but what would happen if
our energy sector collapsed that's
something we may need to think about
it's a big question Rick Perry spent
close to three years as the president's
Secretary of Energy of course he was
governor for three terms one of our
biggest oil producing states Texas we're
happy to have him tonight governor
thanks so much for coming on so it seems
pretty clear that the energy sector is
really threatened and almost nobody
reflexively supports oil companies or
Finers whatever but this seems like a
like a real threat what would happen if
that sector collapsed yeah well Tucker I
think it's important for your viewers to
take into account just what does it what
is the energy industry who is the energy
industry and it's the union workers in
Pennsylvania is the union workers down
in the Texas Gulf Coast it's those
workers out in the Permian Basin up in
the Bakken and North Dakota Pennsylvania
again the pipeline workers out there I
mean there's this host of Americans who
their entire future taking care of their
family paying their mortgages is tied
directly to the the energy industry
it's a driver of
massive amount of our American economy
yeah there are some big companies out
there there's independents out there
that are the real buffer but here's what
you need to keep an eye on if we were to
lose those independent operators and
we're on the verge let me tell you our
capacity is full
the Saudis are flooding this market with
with cheap oil and and I'm telling you
we're on the verge of a massive collapse
of an industry that we worked awfully
hard over the course the last three or
four years to build up to the number one
all in gas producing country in the
world giving Americans some affordable
energy resources if we were to lose that
if if we woke up a year from now and
there were five big companies because
all of these independents were gone out
of business and then there's a company
called Aramco a company called Ross now
the Russians Exxon Mobil and Chevron and
maybe BP if that's it then I would
suggest that would make a lot of
Americans really nervous that that's the
only thing well I agree with that and
man erupted you and just go back to
something you said which is baffling so
the industry's on the verge really of a
collapse and yet we're being flooded
with foreign oil refiners are being
flooded with with foreign oil why are we
allowing that so you bring up an
incredibly important issue here's what I
would do and I certainly would give this
advice to the president is I would for
the next 60 to 90 days not from now on
but from the next 60 to 90 days I would
say refiners we're going to refine US
crude US crude only and that would give
a buffer to the market it would send a
clear message that we're just not going
to let foreign oil flow in here bust our
energy industry and here's the more
important thing Tucker I think that not
only your viewers but everyone in the
administration I think knows well but I
want to reiterate this this is about our
national security this is about
America's ability to defend ourselves if
our independent operators who have led
the shale revolution who has made
America number one in gas producing
country in the world if we lost that
we'd go back to 1974-75 I was a pilot in
the United States Air Force in that
period time I remember what that was
like where we were beholden to countries
that didn't necessarily have our best
interest in mind well about the spigots
of the fuel of us cover just cannot
afford that of course and I don't know
why we would allow our fake allies the
Saudis to flood our market right now and
I and I hope that your recommendation is
acted upon
mr. secretary thanks so much for joining
us and I hope we will talk about maybe
the Treasury Department buying oil
futures I think all of these things make
a lot save the American energy industry
that we work so hard to build up great
to see you thank you for that